flies tackle the health disparities that
afflict so many of our communities
and strengthen strengthen the nation's
public health infrastructure
and medical preparedness and response
programs at every level
i look forward to having more hearings
specific to that work soon and hearing
what our witnesses today have to say on
that subject as well
as federal officials on the front lines
of this pandemic you all have an
important
perspective into the progress we are
making today
as well as the lessons we must learn for
tomorrow
and now i will turn it over to ranking
member senator brewer for his opening
remark
thank you madam chairman i'm glad we're
holding another hearing
to update us on the status of covet 19
response
and to our witnesses thank you for the
work you've done
more importantly welcome back to the
committee it's been almost 18 months
since the initial reports of severe
pneumonia in ruin
ruin of china surfaced since that time
we've tragically seen over a half
million deaths in this country from
cobit 19.
government-backed shutdowns have
jeopardized the livelihood of millions
of americans
and we've spent more taxpayer money than
i could have
ever imagined in response to this virus
and the devastating effect
it's had on our economy but now more
than ever
there's reason for hope we're seeing the
promise of vaccines and treatments
in real time a month ago the case count
in the united states was over seventy
thousand new cases per day
today we're down to roughly forty
thousand and headed south
cdc's projecting continued declines in
death
and hospitalization rates because of
operation warp speed
dr marks dr fauci dr han
the fda we've fully vaccinated 115
million americans with roughly
44 which is referred to 44 of adults
and delivered almost 330 million doses
to states operation warp speed and barta
spent more than 18 billion dollars to
make vaccines available to americans
manufacturing vaccines at risk and the
american people
are benefiting from that today
manufacturers were able to produce
vaccines
enough vaccines but the united states is
now able to
help provide vaccines to countries in
need
like india because of the collaborative
efforts over the last year
we're ready to turn the corner the
partnerships developing and
manufacturing the coveted 19 vaccines
have been one of the biggest scientific
scientific success stories
in generations industry answered the
call at
all the start of at the start of the
pandemic and partnered in an
unprecedented way to bring us these
life-saving products
intellectual property is part of the
reason
we have these life-saving products today
if these protections are not in place
the innovators of life-saving medicines
will not have them for the next pandemic
it's that simple
we hold a hearing on the threat of china
taking intellectual property
from u.s research and now the biden
administration
has agreed just to hand it over
there's a way to support the
manufacturing of vaccines globally
and help countries in need without
acting in bad
faith against innovators who stepped up
when the world needed them the most it's
the partnership we're already seeing
today
that are saving lives not silly ideas
about socializing means of production
the action from the biden administration
to support waiving
intellectual property rights will
undermine the innovation
we're relying on to bring this pandemic
to an
end and will leave us with a less
prepared future
i'm encouraged that some of our european
allies
cautioned against this reckless action
and i hope the adults in the biden
administration will realize that what
sounds good
in a grad school ivory tower thesis
paper
does not make sense in the real world
you four or the adults in the room
i urge you to think about the real
consequences
if we just give away this science and
this technology
the next part of our job is going to be
the difficult part
i've been looking to israel to help
predict the challenges that we may be in
store
for store within the u.s since they're
ahead of us on vaccination rates today
israel was able to vaccinate 40 of the
adult population by the end of february
their data shows that uptake stalled
once they vaccinated about 60 percent of
the adult population
while there are differences between our
countries
we have to use the information we've got
to best predict our road ahead
every adult has the opportunity to be
vaccinated
and supplies starting to exceed demand
in other words we have more shots than
we have arms to put it in
we need to address vaccine hesitancy and
it needs to be done now
i know this is the case in my state with
recent reports from wilmington north
carolina
that local officials are changing their
approach as vaccine demands slow
we must paint a picture for the american
people showing the benefits
of both a vaccination and a reopening of
our country
this is a simple message for those in
leadership
positions i got the vaccine my wife got
the vaccine my sons got the vaccine
their wives got the vaccine
i've encouraged all my staff to take it
as soon as it's available to them and
i've gone through the last 24 hours
with a real fear that i had a one and a
half year old grandson who might have
had covet
fortunately it all came back negative
and he'll
hopefully leave the hospital sometime
today but i would guess that everyone in
this room is vaccinated
which means if we follow the cdc
guidelines
we can dispense with mask and social
distancing
tomorrow i hope that we're going to have
a vaccine that's approved
for kids over 12
and one one's younger hopefully in the
not too distant future
we must assure we reassure americans
that coveted vaccines
are safe vaccines save
lives i might have been naive
when we started this believing that
staying out of the hospital
and not dying might have been motivation
enough to get people vaccinated
it clearly wasn't and that's why we must
assure
reassure americans that if you get a
covet vaccine
our lives can and will return to normal
but we can't assure without painting
that picture form
what that looks like today's response
is preparing us for tomorrow's threat as
senator murray said we've launched a
joint effort to strengthen our public
health preparedness programs
for the next threat which we will
inevitably face
that threat could be emerging uh today
or
it could be a new virus another
curveball from mother nature
or the result of deliberate man-made
attacks on our country
our framework has always been flexible
and it needs to stay that
way there will always be lessons that we
learn from each response and our threat
landscape
is constantly evolving our experience
with this
pandemic has made that even more clear
senator murray and i look forward to
working with each of you
and the members of the committee on this
project to take stock of
lessons learned and to actually put them
into action
today to our witnesses today thank you
for all you've done up to this point of
the response but know that the
most challenging days may be the next
several weeks and months ahead
as we attempt to get to a vaccination
level
that changes the glad path to one that's
permanently in the decline
with that i thank the chair thank you
senator burr and i look forward to
working with you on that and i wish your
grandson well thank you
i will now introduce today's witnesses
dr richelle wellensky
is the director of the centers for
disease control and prevention and the
administrator of the agency for toxic
substances and disease registry dr
polanski welcome back thank you for
joining us today
next i'd like to introduce dr anthony
vouche who is the director of the
national institute of allergy and
infectious diseases
and the chief medical advisor on private
president biden's kova 19 response team
dr fauci good to have you back before
the committee as well thank you for
joining us
dr peter marks is the center is the
director of the center for biologics
evaluation
and research for the food and drug
administration dr marx we're glad to
have you here again as well thank you
and finally i would like to introduce dr
david kessler dr kessler is the chief
science officer of the biden
administration's coven 19 response dr
kessler glad to have you with us as well
uh with that we will begin our witness
testimony dr wolinski will begin with
you for your opening statement
thank you chairman murray ranking member
burr and members of the committee for
the invitation to speak with you today
i last testified before this committee
less than two months ago
since that time the dedicated
professionals at cdc
have been working diligently to provide
additional resources
to states localities territories and
tribes
thanks to support from congress we are
updating our guidance
based on the latest scientific evidence
and we are working with our partners
around the country and around the globe
to reduce the burden of covet 19.
i am pleased to report that since
january we have seen a consistent
downward trend with daily averages of
new infections dropping
76 hospitalizations down 71 percent
and reported deaths decreasing by 75
this progress is also reflected in our
data on the county level risk
just a few months ago 85 percent of all
counties in the u.s were experiencing
high covet 19 transmission rates and
increased community risk
this morning that is down to 33 percent
of counties
these trends give me hope and still i
continue to emphasize that we must
remain diligent and committed to our
surveillance and prevention efforts
because the emergence of variants
could set us back with your help cdc is
using the 1.7 billion dollars congress
provided to expand
nation
my genomic sequencing efforts since
january we have dramatically increased
sequence output from 3 000 samples per
week
to approximately 35 000 samples per week
we are also keeping our commitment to
prioritize health equity
since march we have announced a number
of investments that
center in health equity these include
2.25 billion dollars to address coven 19
related
health disparities and advance health
equity among high risk and underserved
populations
three billion dollars to strengthen
vaccine confidence with a focus on
increasing
uptake and equity in administration
particularly
in communities hardest hit by the
pandemic
332 million dollars in community health
workers to support coven 19 prevention
and control and 250 million dollars to
develop
targeted strategies for vaccine
education and outreach
for uptake in specific communities
in addition cdc continues to update our
guidance as we learn more
this includes a recent update outlining
levels of risk of activities for fully
vaccinated and unvaccinated people
we will continue to update this guidance
to be clear that vaccines are a means of
returning to activities we stopped
as a result of the pandemic i am so
proud to report the administration of
more than 261 million
vaccine doses including more than 131
33 million since i last testified before
you in march
on over 84 percent of americans age 65
and older
and over 58 percent of all adult
americans have now received at least one
vaccine dose
with these cases trending down in the
united states and more people getting
vaccinated
we are cautiously optimistic however
globally the pandemic is more severe
than ever
india's surge of cases is tragic and a
reminder that the virus can rapidly
outstrip our efforts to contain it
if we are not careful we will not end
this pandemic without working
hand-in-hand with countries around the
globe to fight
covet 19. i want to take a moment to
acknowledge that while we have made
great progress over the last few months
more than
579 000 people in the united states have
died from covet 19 during this pandemic
and just since i saw you in march over
39
000 of our loved ones have died from
covet 19
in the united states every death is a
stark reminder of why we must remain
vigilant
and focused to end this pandemic as
quickly as possible
i want to close with a promise and an
appeal to the american people
my promise is that cdc will continue to
follow the science as our guide
and my appeal is to implore everyone to
get a covid19 vaccine
as soon as possible as the fastest way
to end this pandemic
but even with this powerful tool while
we continue to have community
transmission
we must also maintain public health
measures we know will prevent the spread
of this virus
mask hygiene hand hygiene and physical
distancing
finally as we get through this pandemic
we must work together
over the months and years ahead to build
on the investments
partnerships and innovations that we
have created
during this crisis this includes
achieving sustainable investments in
public health infrastructure
to be better prepared for whatever comes
next
it is one way we can turn tragedy into
lasting progress
and improved health for all thank you
again for the opportunity and invitation
to testify today and i look forward to
answering your questions
thank you dr fatchi of chair
ranking member members of the committee
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to discuss with you this morning
the role of the national institute of
allergy and infectious diseases and the
nih
in research addressing the covet 19
pandemic
as i had mentioned to this committee
during the last hearing that we attended
we have a strategic plan that has four
major components
fundamental knowledge of the virus
diagnostics
therapeutics and the development of safe
and effective vaccines
for the purpose of today's discussion i
will focus
on the issue of vaccines we often get
asked how it could be possible
that the virus was discovered in january
of 2020
and we had doses of vaccine going into
the arms of individuals a vaccine that
was
highly efficacious and safe 11 months
later
in december of 2020. well the story
behind that
has been the decades of investment in
basic and clinical
biomedical research that has led to our
ability to
to accomplish this extraordinary feat
just some examples the basic preclinical
and clinical research
in developing vaccine platform
technology
particularly the highly successful mrna
platform in addition scientists
at the vaccine research center at niaid
as well as grantees and contracts
contractors
throughout the country developed the
optimal
immunogen which is the conformationally
correct spike protein
which is used by virtually all the
vaccines that are being tested right now
and finally the utilization of a
clinical trial network
that we had set up decades ago for
influenza
and for hiv when one thinks of
efficacy it really is what are the
results of a clinical trial
often when you get into the real world
the effectiveness of vaccines
falls short of the original efficacy
that is not at all the case with the
vaccines for covert 19
because the real world effectiveness is
even more impressive
than the results of the clinical trial
one example
the university of texas looked at 23 000
of their employees and found that the
incidence of infection was 0.05 percent
markedly lower than on vaccinated
individuals
the cdc has multiple mmwrs
reporting on various aspects of the real
world effectiveness
importantly a recent paper in the lancet
reported on the experience in israel
which as senator burr had mentioned has
done an extraordinary job of getting
their citizens vaccinated and what we
have seen
is a remarkable diminution in the number
of infections
that reached a critical turning point
when they reached a certain percentage
of the individuals who were vaccinated
it wasn't only limited
to israel another recent paper in the
country of
qatar showed a similar type of a result
in which not only was the mrna vaccine
highly
effective in over 300 000 individuals
tested in preventing the original
wild-type
virus but it also had a very interesting
capability
of protecting against mild to moderate
disease
of a problematic variant from south
africa the 351
and protected virtually a hundred
percent from severe disease including
hospitalization and death and so
when the president makes the goal of
seventy percent
of adults receiving at least one vaccine
by the fourth of july we believe that
that is
an attainable goal the reason we feel
it's important
is that i believe that we are about at
that critical turning point
when we get a certain percentage we
don't know exactly what it is but
clearly the majority of individuals in
the country vaccinated
we will see a sharp turning point and a
marked diminution
in cases and so as i said the last time
i testified before you
we are in a race between the vaccine
and the virus if left to its own devices
will continue to surge
based on experience thus far in this
country
and globally i feel confident that if we
continue to vaccinate
people at the rate that we're doing that
we will very soon have a situation
where we will have so few infections in
this country
we will begin to return to the normality
that all of us desire so much thank you
very much
thank you uh dr marks
chair murray ranking member burp
distinguished members of the committee
thank you for the opportunity to testify
before you again
to describe fda's continued covet 19
response efforts and particularly our
efforts on vaccines
first yesterday evening the fda
announced the expansion of the emergency
use authorization
for the pfizer bioentec covert 19
vaccine to include
adolescents down to age 12 years
we know that this is a big step for our
country as vaccinating a younger
population can bring us closer to a
sense of normalcy
and to ending this pandemic to look at
the safety of the vaccine
the fda evaluated a clinical trial of
more than 2 000 adolescents
aged 12 through 15. half of the
participants received the pfizer
bioentec vaccine
and half received a saline placebo the
side effects experienced by those
aged 12 through 15 were similar to those
experienced by
individuals aged 16 and older to look at
effectiveness
the fda evaluated data about how
participants immune systems responded to
the vaccine
comparing 190 individuals aged 12
through 15
to 170 age 16 through 25.
the fda also evaluated data on cases of
covet 19
in among adolescents aged 12 through 15
seven days after the second dose of
vaccine was given
and no cases of covet 19 occurred among
a thousand and five adolescents who
received the vaccine
compared to 16 cases in 978 placebo
recipients thus indicating the vaccine
was completely effective
in preventing covet 19 in the trial
that was symptomatic uh parents and
guardians can rest assured
that the agency undertook a rigorous and
thorough review of all available
scientific data as we have
with all of our covit 19 vaccine
authorizations
and the cdc's advisory committee on
immunization practices will next review
the data tomorrow
also we as we announced yesterday we
intend to convene a virtual meeting
of the vaccines and related biological
advisory committee on june 10
2021 during which we'll provide a status
update
on our approach to emergency use
authorization individuals
aged 12 through 17 years of age and
we'll also discuss the data needed to
support an emergency
authorization and a biologics license
application in children less than
age 12. second as covet 19 vaccination
expands into adolescence we continue to
work diligently with cdc and other
partners on safety surveillance of the
authorized vaccines
we're grateful to congress for the
american rescue plan funds which are
supporting expanded vaccine
safety surveillance among other critical
priorities
we've seen that our safety surveillance
systems are doing what they're supposed
to do in detecting
important adverse events recently our
surveillance systems detected a safety
signal for rare blood clots and low
blood platelets
known as thrombosis thrombocytopenia
syndrome with the yanson or johnson
johnson covid19 vaccine
following a brief pause taken to
evaluate the situation situation and
educate providers
based on the rare but increased risk of
this adverse event
mainly in women age 12 age 18 through 50
years of age
fda modified the fact sheet for health
care providers to include a warning
pertaining to the risk of thrombosis
with thrombocytopenia
and the fact sheets for recipients and
caregivers was also updated
we'll continue to diligently monitor the
safety of all of these vaccines
third the cdcc and fda are working
closely together to track the emergence
and the spread of covet 19 variants
currently available evidence suggests
that the three available
fda authorized vaccines adequately
addressed covet 19 variants circulating
in the united states
however we're working with manufacturers
and government partners
to plan the composition of the vaccine
so that we can administer booster
vaccinations if
necessary of an appropriate composition
fourth the fda recently completed an
inspection of emergent bile solutions a
proposed manufacturing facility for the
yanson
covid19 vaccine at the close of the
inspection of emergent biosolutions
fda investigators cited several
observations concerning whether the
facilities practices met or regulatory
requirements and standards
we're now working with emergent bile
solutions to address the conditions
identified
it's been made public that no product
has been released from this facility for
use in the united states
and will not agree to the release of any
product from this facility until we're
truly confident that it meets our
expectations for quality
additionally moving forward the agency
is refining how to optimally evaluate
the manufacturing quality during this
and any
future public health emergency we're
committed to maintaining the trust
of the public in the vaccines and hope
that every ill
eligible individual consider getting
vaccinated to help
end this pandemic thank you
thank you dr kessler
chair murray ranking member burr
distinguished members
of the committee thank you for the
invitation to provide an update
on our covet 19 response
allow me to succinctly set out what we
are focused on today
first we have delivered today date 330
million doses
of vaccine in the united states and have
administered
over 260 million of them
the most important thing we all need to
do
is to get a vaccine to everyone who
wants to be vaccinated
in the united states the current vaccine
supply exceeds demand
nothing is more important than achieving
the president's goal
of having 70 of adults with at least
one shah before by july
4. the long-term fate
of many of our communities depends
on getting people vaccinated there are
many reasons why people
have not yet been vaccinated
we need to recognize at the core for
many
is simply a fear of the unknown
all the data support the basic
proposition
that these vaccines are safe
and effective getting vaccinated
will prevent hospitalization and death
second the fda took a significant step
yesterday in the fight against covet 19
by expanding the finest eua to
adolescence
ages 12 to 15. pending the
recommendation
of the acip tomorrow we plan to offer
the pfizer vaccine
to all young people ages 12 to 15.
right now the pfizer vaccine is
available at many local pharmacies
and larger health clinics we are working
to make smaller trays available
so that the pfizer vaccine can be
administered by more pediatricians
family doctors and rural health care
providers by late fall we expect to have
data on the safety
and effectiveness of vaccines for
children
under 12. third we are planning
and i underscore the word planning to
have booster doses
available if necessary for the american
people
in increased age the natural waning of
antibodies over time and new variants
all increase the probability that
booster doses
may be needed fourth it is absolutely
essential
that we begin sharing doses made in the
united states
with the rest of the world supplying
other nations with vaccines is not just
the right thing to do
for life-saving humanitarian purposes
it is also in the best interest of the
united states
to mitigate the risk of viral evolution
fifth we need to hasten our search for
an
antiviral i am concerned that even
after we finish vaccinating most of the
people who want to be vaccinated
by this summer there will still be a
significant number of cases
and an unacceptable number of deaths
people who are immunosuppressed
who do not mountain immune response for
a number of reasons
or choose not to be vaccinated will
continue to be vulnerable
and we need options for them the
antibody treatments are one approach
but a simple oral antiviral can add
to our armamentarium to bring this
epidemic
under control lastly we need to build a
program
for vaccine preparedness for future
pandemics
this will need to be done in partnership
with the private sector
and build on all the lessons we have
learned today thank you for the
opportunity to testify today
and i look forward to your questions
thank you
uh to all of our witnesses for being
here today in your testimony
we will now begin around the five-minute
questions of our witnesses and i ask our
colleagues keep track of your clock and
stay within those five minutes we do
have votes starting at 11
30 today dr fauci um let me start with
you the surge of covet 19 that is
devastating india is a painful reminder
really that
we can't end the pandemic here until we
end it everywhere
and i'm glad the biden administration is
leading that global fight
by rejoining the world health
organization and funding global vaccine
efforts
and committing to donate 60 million
astrazeneca vaccines to other countries
by july 4th
india's outbreak really underscores the
need for a robust public health
infrastructure in the u.s to respond
appropriately to this pandemic
and future outbreaks as well i want to
ask you today dr
fauci what can we learn from the india
from india's outbreak that we should
apply to our response here in the u.s
well i think one of the important things
is don't ever underestimate
the situation you know the reason that
india is in such dire straits now
is that they had an original surge and
made the incorrect assumption that they
were finished
with it and what happened they opened up
prematurely
and wind up having a surge right now
that we're all very well aware of is
extremely
devastating that's the first thing the
second thing is preparedness with regard
to public health preparedness
which we as a lesson learned for future
pandemics have to realize that we need
to continue to build up
our local public health infrastructure
which over the last
decades we have let actually in many
respects go into disarray
likely because of our successes in
controlling so many
diseases the other lesson that's
learning madam chair
is that this is a global pandemic that
requires
a global response and we need to pay
attention
to the responsibility that we have not
only for our own country but to join
with other countries
to make sure that we have the access
to interventions particularly vaccines
throughout the world
because if it continues to have dynamics
of virus
anywhere in the world we have a threat
here in the united states particularly
with variants and you know there's one
variant
in india that is also a new variant
number
one 617b617 so those are just a few of
the lessons that i believe we can take
from what's going on
in india thank you thank you um dr marks
i'm really encouraged by how the fda has
worked both quickly and
carefully to get multiple code vaccines
authorized but having said that
i am very concerned about the reports
involving emergent biosolutions you
mentioned in your marks
it is a contractor that received 628
million dollars
to manufacture covid vaccines and wanted
to ask you to explain
fda's recent findings because after
receiving reports of cross-contamination
with another vaccine
fda inspected the emergent facility she
said and asked the contractor to pause
manufacturing
and the cross-contaminated vaccine was
not distributed for any use
but dr marks what steps is fda taking to
make sure the quality
safety and effectiveness of all covenant
19 vaccines yeah chair mary thank you
for that question
so we're currently for the emergent
facility we're actively
working with all of the parties involved
to ensure that the facilities
uh deficiencies are all remediated so
that before they actually
are able to release vaccine it meets all
of our
quality standards that americans deserve
from vaccines
also as we move on uh to other
facilities
that may be producing vaccines
we will take the approach of using all
of our inspectional tools
to ensure that the quality of those is
the highest nature
and as with all of our biologics
license applications we for that
generally
will be performing on-site inspections
of those facilities
uh to ensure the quality of those
products
thank you and i'm i'm really deeply
concerned about what happened and my
expectation is in the future
nothing like that happens again um dr
wolenski in my last minute here let me
just
ask you the cdc says that while fewer
children have been sick
with coca-19 compared to adults children
can be infected get
sick and spread the virus with the uh
authorization pete of pfizer yesterday
for
children 12 to 15 what would you say to
parents who are considering getting
their kids vaccinated now
i would encourage all parents to get
their children vaccinated i know many
parents are enthusiastic and have been
texting me can't wait to get their
children vaccinated um i recognize that
there some parents want to sort of see
how it goes first but i am encouraging
all parents to get their children
vaccinated
some parents won't want to be first but
i'm also encouraging children to ask for
the vaccine
i have a 16 year old myself and i can
tell you he wanted to get the vaccine he
wants his life back these kids want to
go back to school they want to go back
to the things they love
thank you senator burr
thank you chairman um dr kessler
we've shipped 2.7 million doses of
astrazeneca i think to mexico
that's the only country we've shipped to
we've got additional doses of
astrazeneca
in inventory in this country we talked
about july 4th
exporting more why have we not taken the
astrazeneca which is not approved for
vaccination in the united states why
have we not mobilized that to other
countries the world today
mr senator it's a very important
question um
[Music]
we have um shipped uh a total of four
million doses uh to date
including uh to mexico and
i believe 1.5 to canada
we are ready um to ship uh
up to 60 million doses
of astrazeneca but as the chair pointed
out
and as my colleague dr marks responded
there are issues with emergent that are
under review by the food and drug
administration
if and when those issues are resolved
and we can say that these are quality
doses we will do just as you say
correct me if i'm wrong i didn't think
the emergent baltimore facility had
anything to do with astrazeneca
production am i wrong dr marks
us senator byrne no the their uh the
astrazeneca vaccine was being produced
in that facility and
uh the fda feels it's imperative that
before
vaccine can be shipped to any other
partner it has to meet the quality
standards that it would meet for
any american as well so how long do you
anticipate that
testing the astrazeneca vaccines that's
currently manufactured
would take to verify we are working on
that as quickly as we can we understand
the imperative here there is a working
group
across our office of regulatory affairs
and our center and others at fda that
are working together to try to
clear that uh those doses as quickly as
we can
um i can't give you an exact time but we
understand the imperative to be able to
have them available so that dr kessler
can arrange
for them to be shipped to those in need
okay dr kessler one of the reasons we
are as successful today is that
partnerships have been leveraging um
vaccinations around the world and
over 275 partnerships have been created
to scale up
vaccine production manufacturing and
[Music]
i guess i'm asking you this if we waive
intellectual property in the united
states
do we not stand the risk of
affecting innovation in the future when
if we did it to scale up manufacturing
capacity
the private sector has done that through
partnerships already
and that's the reason that we've been so
successful shouldn't we let the private
sector continue to do something
that i think dr fauci and i have said in
the past we
never innovated this this is novel that
they would have the relationship to do
it
why why mess with a good thing i applaud
the actions the pharmaceutical
industry senator this is a
once in a century pandemic
i think we all recognize that
extraordinary circumstances call for
extraordinary mess
measures we know and i agree with you
senator
that a waiver alone won't result in the
scale and speed we need to make enough
vaccines
to end the pandemic that's why
we will continue to ramp up our efforts
working with the private sector and all
possible partners
to expand vaccine manufacturing uh
and distribution around that around the
world
i mean our job is to do as you say
to increase uh that supply that's what
we're focused on
and we want to make vaccines available
to the world david here's the reality
when pfizer went to
open up its kansas plant to produce
vaccine it took them i believe seven
months
to retool and to get everything done
this belief that you can
export intellectual property and you're
going to have a stand up around the
world instantaneously of vaccine
production is a joke
dr marx has already expressed concern
over the backlogs for inspections
um and how long would it take for us to
inspect foreign sites if in fact
there was a vaccine pool that found its
way in and out of the united states
let me just get this before my time runs
out um
can anybody give me the number there's
been 33 million
americans infected with covet that have
actually tested positive
how many of that 33 million have then
been vaccinated
anybody know what that number is
here's here's why i make the point and
here's why i think it's relevant
um if we're looking at a certain number
that we don't know exactly what it is dr
fauci that we want to get to
and we've vaccinated 115 million
it's important for us to know of the
counted vaccine number
how many of those already had protection
because they were coveted positive
so if if we're trying to reach a number
when
the president says 70 vaccination if we
get to 65 vaccinated and
percent got coveted and they have
protection isn't that like being at 70
i think one of the problems that the
goal post continues to see
be too far and we've now got the harder
part of how do we take the
40 that aren't real comfortable with
getting vaccinated
and at least have a shot at vaccinating
50 percent of that 40 percent
and it may be that our number is higher
today
on the protected i know it is i don't
think 33 million have all been
vaccinated that were positive
but i think it's absolutely crucial that
we figure out what that number is
not sure whose responsibility it is that
we figure out what that number is
and put that into our formula of how
many americans
have protections i thank the chair thank
you senator brewer senator casey
uh jim murray thank you very much and i
want to thank our
our guests dr fauci dr kessler dr marks
and dr wolinski i think i'll
have at least one question for dr
wilinski and one for
dr marks i'm going to start with you dr
wolinski
i want to thank you for your leadership
and the leadership of the
cdc and your efforts to ensure that
children and adolescents are
up to date on vaccinations particularly
as students return to in-person learning
and you noted
you and others have noted there are over
11 million
doses to the vaccines for children
program that have been missed these
missed doses could seriously and
negatively impact
efforts to protect children their
families in the in communities from
vaccine preventable diseases and
conditions of course we're talking here
about
diseases other than covet 19 at the same
time
with 12 to 15 year olds now able to get
vaccinated against covet 19
there's an even greater need to ensure
parents are aware
of all the vaccines all the vaccines
that children should receive in order to
remain healthy
the rescue plan contains funding to
build vaccine confidence
and specifically includes provisions to
ensure
funding is allocated towards increasing
vaccination rates
throughout the us so here's the question
doctor in addition to the public
awareness efforts that you and cdc have
already undertaken
will the cdc be releasing the funding to
both states and communities
to ensure that children and adolescents
are caught up on
both routine and recommended
vaccinations particularly as
children return to in-person learning
thank you senator for that you raise an
issue that is
near and dear to my heart and i'm very
worried about um more than
20 percent of our measles vaccines were
not used this year
we have the same issue with
meningococcal vaccines and especially
among our adolescents
unfortunately we actually don't have
data on whether we can co-administer the
cova-19 vaccine
and other routine immunizations and
whether we get the same protection from
the kova 19 vaccines
and the routine administration of other
immunizations
that is one issue that the experts at
acip are going to address tomorrow as to
whether that can safely be done and that
we could potentially
get adequate protection you are right we
need to as we're
putting forward these efforts in vaccine
confidence for the kova 19 vaccine
we need to take this outreach and make
sure that we are
breaching these communities and not only
conveying the importance of getting the
cova 19 vaccine but if we are not
able to co-administer them to make sure
we get back to these children
and be able to code to administer the
routine vaccines that they have lost
before the school year in terms of
the funding though that will be released
any sense of the timing of that
i do not but we can get back to you okay
thank you
dr marks i wanted to start with you
regarding um
pfizer and we've heard a lot this year
about emergency use authorization
and we know that pfizer's recently filed
their application for
full licensure of their cova 19
vaccine um i think we get a lot of
questions
uh at home on a range of these issues in
in particular
what does it mean uh what does it mean
what does full licensure mean
uh one of the concerns that we've hear
we've heard a lot about is
um the the uh
the vaccines are provided this emergency
use
authorization but what is what is
what's the next step for for a vaccine
can you explain what it means to to get
full licensure that's
question number one and secondly what
additional information would a company
need to submit
beyond what was required just for
so-called eua senator thanks very much
for that question
the full licensure um is
something that a manufacturer submits
with a full data package which i'll go
into in a moment but i just want to go
back to to pick up on something that
dr fauci said these covet 19 vaccines
they were expedited
um not by cutting corners but by going
through
a development plan in which kind of
empty space
that space that would have been normally
just not stuff happening
was taken away so manufacturing was done
while the clinical trials were done
the large clinical trial programs were
of the size
of normally licensed vaccines in the
united states
the one place where we're a little bit
short was the duration of safety
follow-up but
we are very confident from the amount of
safety fault at least a meeting of two
months
safety follow-up on this safety data set
for the emergency use authorization
that the large majority of adverse
events became apparent so
we're very confident in recommending
these vaccines
for everyone our families all americans
the difference that will happen with the
biologics license application is that
the manufacturers will be able to submit
additional safety data
perhaps six months of safety data rather
than just the median two-month safety
data
and additionally there are some
technical things that will be there
that many people may not care a lot
about but we do
that is manufacturing conformance lots
the
uh formal facilities inspections will
occur um
and additional ancillary studies will be
put in that package so
um i think the main message to the
american public is that
for all intents and purposes the vaccine
that's being used
um is very close to what we would
normally have in a biologics license
application
there are some little things around the
margins that will go into the
biologics license application when we
have a formal approval
thank you thank you jim murray senator
paul
dr falchi we don't know whether the
pandemic started in a lab in wuhan
or evolved naturally but we should want
to know
three million people have died from this
pandemic and that should cause us to
explore all possibilities
instead government authorities
self-interested in continuing
gain of function research say there's
nothing to see here
gain of function research as you know is
juicing up naturally occurring
animal viruses to infect humans to
arrive at the truth
the us government should admit that the
wuhan virology institute
was experimenting to enhance the
coronavirus's ability to infect humans
juicing up super viruses is not new
scientists in the u.s have long known
how to mutate animal viruses to infect
humans
for years dr ralph barrick a virologist
in the u.s
has been collaborating with dr xi xengli
of the wuhan virology institute sharing
his discoveries about how to create
super viruses
this gain of function research has been
funded by the nih
the collaboration between the u.s and
the wuhan virology institute continues
doctors barrick and she worked together
to insert bat
virus spike protein into the backbone of
the deadly sars virus
and then used this man-made supervirus
to infect
human airway cells think about that for
a moment
the sars virus had a 15 mortality
we're fighting a pandemic that has about
a one percent mortality can you imagine
if a sars virus that's been juiced up
and had viral proteins added to it to
the spike protein
if that were released accidentally
dr fauci do you still support funding of
the
nih funding of the lab in wuhan
senator paul with all due respect you
are entirely
entirely and completely incorrect
that the nih has not ever and does not
now
fund gain of function research
in the wuhan institute do they find dr
barrick
we do not fund do you [ __ ] dr
barracks kane of function research
dr barrett does not doing gain or
function research and if it is
it's according to the guidelines and it
is being conducted
in north carolina i don't think it's
concerning a bat virus spike protein
that he got from the wuhan institute
into the sars viruses gain of function
that is not a minority because at least
200
scientists have signed a statement from
the cambridge working group
saying that it is gain of function well
it is not
and if you look at the grant and you
look at the progress reports
it is not gain a function despite the
fact
that people tweet that so you're trying
to support sending money to the wuhan
virology institute
we do not send money now to do one hun
sending money we did under your tutelage
we were sending it through eco health it
was a sub agency
and a sub grant do you support the money
from nih that was going to the wuhan
institute
let me explain to you why that was done
the saws cov1 originated
in bats in china it would have been
irresponsible of us if we did not
investigate the bat viruses
and the serology to see who might have
been or perhaps it would be in china
possible to send it to the chinese
government that we may not be able to
trust with this
uh knowledge and with this uh incredibly
dangerous viruses
government scientists like yourself who
favor gain of function
i don't favor gain of function research
in china you're saying
that are not correct government
defenders of gain of function
such as yourself say that covid19
mutations were random and not designed
by man
but interestingly the technique that dr
barrick developed
forces mutations by serial passage
through cell culture
that the mutations appear to be natural
in fact dr barrack named the technique
the nosium technique
because the mutations appear naturally
nicholas baker
in the new york magazine said nobody
would know if the virus had been
fabricated in a laboratory or grown in
nature
governor authorities in the u.s
including yourself unequivocally deny
that covet 19
could have escaped a lab but even dr xi
in wuhan wasn't so sure
according to nicholas baker dr she
wondered could this new virus have come
from her own laboratory
she checked her records frantically and
found no matches
that really took a load off my mind she
said i had not slept for days
the director of the gain of function
research in wuhan couldn't sleep because
she was terrified that it might be in
her lab
dr barrick an advocate of gain of
function research admits
the main problem that the institute of
virology has is the outbreak occurred in
close proximity
what are the odds barrick responded
could you rule out a laboratory escape
the answer in this case is probably not
will you in front of this group
categorically say that the kovid 19
could not have occurred through serial
passage in a laboratory
i do not have any accounting of what the
chinese
may have done and i'm fully in favor of
any further
investigation of what went on in china
however
i will repeat again the nih
and niaid categorically
has not funded gain of function research
to be conducted in the wuhan institute
of iran you support it in the u.s we
have 11 labs doing it and you have
allowed it here we have a committee to
do it but the committee is granted every
exemption
you're you're fooling with mother nature
here you're allowing super viruses to be
created
with a 15 mortality it's very dangerous
and it was a huge mistake to share this
with china
and it's a huge mistake to allow this to
continue in the united states
and we should be very careful to
investigate where this virus came from
i fully agree that you should
investigate where the virus
came from but again we have not funded
gain of function research on this virus
in the wuhan institute of virology no
matter parsing words your parts say it
there was
research there was research done with dr
she and dr barrack they have
collaborated on gain of function
research
where they enhanced the sars virus to
infect
human airway cells and they did it by
merging
a new spike protein on it that is gain
of function
that was joint research between the
wuhan institute
and dr barrick you can't deny it senator
paul your time
time has expired dr fatchi i will let
you respond to that when we need to move
on
excuse me i will allow you to respond to
that and then we'll move on
yeah i mean i just wanted to say we i i
don't know how many times i can say it
madam chair
we did not fund gain of function
research to be conducted in the wuhan
institute
of virology thank you senator smith
thank you chair murray and uh thank you
so much to our
panelists for being here today um
i want to just following up on that
exchange
uh just asked dr fauci a question
dr fauci what is the impact
of conspiracy theories peddled by
senator rand paul
and others on americans willingness
to take this vaccine a vaccine
that by all accounts is remarkable
for its safety and efficacy
well conspiracy theories certainly are
not helpful in what we're trying to do i
guess i can say that with some degree of
confidence
well i would agree and i think in this
moment you know we are
at a critical moment for the our
response to this pandemic
and in only 14 months since we uh this
pandemic started
we are here today to acknowledge that we
have 261 million doses of vaccine in
people's arms we have
over 58 of americans with at least one
dose and this is an incredible
and um an incredible accomplishment
and we also know that we have more work
to do and it seems to me that we ought
to be
focused on that work we have to make
sure that our
comprehensive strategy uh that you have
been working on
uh dr fauci for a long time and i'm so
grateful for the
support that you're getting from the
biden harris administration a
comprehensive strategy that is around
vaccinations
around surveillance testing around
treatment social distancing and masks
and also centering our work around
health equity i mean this is what
we need to be really focused on seems to
me
i'd like to ask dr uh walensky a
question about how we go about this
question
of on this issue of getting people
getting vaccines into people's arms now
vaccines and acceptance of vaccines seem
to be really a spectrum from people that
are gung-ho and ready to go to people
who have
a serious resistance to taking vaccines
and we're seeing some learning it seems
to me about what works i have a great
example
of that in duluth minnesota
where public health nurses set up a
pop-up vaccine clinic at the duluth
transportation center and minnesotans
who are taking their bus home are going
to pick up their children at child
care can go to that vaccine pop-up
clinic fill out their paperwork and get
their shot
all in one dose so it's breaking down
some of the logistical challenges that a
lot of
americans and minnesotans still have and
they're they're finding
just great success there was a story in
minnesota public radio
uh just in the last couple of days about
a woman named karen moore who was
waiting to get the vaccine
and hoping that she would be able to get
it at a convenient location
and was able to do it all in one spot
and that made all the difference in the
world to her in terms of overcoming her
so-called vaccine hesitancy which wasn't
hesitancy it was just
the logistics challenges so dr wolenski
can you
tell us a little bit about what the cdc
is doing working with states and
localities to deploy methods like we're
seeing in duluth minnesota
um to help people get easy access to
vaccines
thank you much so much senator um we
have uh spent
three billion dollars uh getting money
to states and localities to
advance these efforts and trying to get
vaccines into people
and to enrich vaccine confidence i would
invite all of you to take out your cell
phones and to text
get vex 438 829 you put in your zip code
you get a list of all the back
places where vaccines are available to
you you can do that by an 800 number or
you can go to vaccines.gov and type your
zip code and find out which vaccines are
available nearby to you
so we're trying to make it we're working
to make it easy we do have to do some of
the pivoting as you discussed and
and ensure that places now have pop-up
sites they have mobile vaccination units
that we are reaching out to rural
communities
that we're putting vaccines in federally
qualified health care centers
that we um have uh we can do this
campaign now a campaign with 5 000
community corps members from everyone
from nascar
and nfl to infectious disease society of
america to faith-based
organizations spending our messages
being the trusted messengers and we're
starting to see the effects of this work
just this morning cbc released new
racial and equity data
on how we're doing in reaching racial
and ethnic minorities with vaccines
the bar graph now shows not just our
overall progress but what we've done in
the last two weeks and in the last two
weeks we've been
really successful in reaching racial and
ethnic minorities in ways we hadn't up
until this time
so we have to do more we recognize we
have to do more we have vaccine
confidence consults that you can
locals and states can call the cdc and
say we're having a hard time reaching
people in this community
what are the things that we can do this
is just a brief list of the many many
activities that we are engaged with
every single day
to get vaccines into people for
and to recognize that all hesitancy is
not the same flavor some people it's
convenient some people want to
understand the science more
some people just need the time off thank
you so much thank you madam chair i want
to just say i appreciate the work of the
cdc and others to support the
innovative and uh strategic efforts of
states
like mine to overcome some of those
barriers
thank you thank you so much senator
senator collins
thank you dr wolanski
i used to have the utmost respect for
the guidance from the cdc
i always considered the cdc to be the
gold
standard i don't anymore
and i want to give you three examples
where i
think the conflicting confusing
guidance from your agency has
undermined public confidence and
contradicts the scientific guidance
of many experts the first
has to do with school openings an issue
that we've talked about before
the new york post reported that a
powerful teachers union
the aft successfully secured changes
verbatim in draft guidance on school
reopenings
this came about because
of an outside group that did a foia
request
that revealed extensive interactions
between
the aft and the cdc
this has been described by dr
monica gandhi a professor
who has written extensively about the
coronavirus
as very very troubling she's referring
to the
emails back and forth between the cdc
and the
aft and she says this is not
how science-based guidance should work
or be put together my second example
is from a new york times story that
appeared
today it talks about cdc
guidelines on math squaring and in
where the cdc announced that less than
10 of covet 19
transmission was occurring outdoors
the article points out that this is
quote almost
certainly misleading and goes on to say
there is not a single documented covet
infection
anywhere in the world from casual
outdoor interactions such as walking
past someone
on a street or eating at a nearby
table the third example
has to do with new guidance the cdc
has issued for summer camps
and here are the reactions of two
experts
one a pediatric immunologist
at columbia referred to the
recommendations
as quote senseless the
editor-in-chief of the journal of the
american medical association pediatrics
called the guidance quote unfairly
draconian so here we have
unnecessary barriers to reopening
schools
exaggerating the risks of outdoor
transmission and unworkable
restrictions on summer camps
why does this matter it matters because
it
undermines public confidence
in your recommendations in the
recommendations that
do make sense in the recommendations
that americans
should be following
i'd like you to respond to
why the cdc is
not following the standard procedures
why it's having offline secret
negotiations with one stakeholder
that was revealed only through reporting
and a foia request why it is
exaggerating outdoor transmission
we know that masks make a big difference
indoors
they don't outdoors
thank you for that question um maybe if
i could take each of your examples one
by one
first the school guidance as a matter of
practice the cdc
um engages with stakeholders with
consumers who
take our guidance who use our guidance
before it is finalized so we can
understand whether it addresses their
needs
for our school guidance we did that with
50 different stakeholders over 50
actually i personally engage with both
parents and teachers
and many different stakeholders to
address what could have
been done to improve the gut the draft
guides we had
one of those stakeholders recognized
that in our guidance we had
addressed what you do if you have
immunocompromised children at severe
at risk of severe disease but we had
neglected in our draft
to address what happens if you have
immunocompromised teachers
teachers who are getting chemotherapy
who have immunocompromising diseases
the request was that we add some
language for what happens if you have
immunocompromised teachers and how they
should behave in school
that is what we did we used cdc based
science
to make that addition but the request
was
to address what happens if you have
immuno-compromised teachers and that was
an oversight
in our initial draft and we included a
science-based response
or a science-based language in our
guidance
with regard to the new york times piece
this morning there's a
meta-analysis from journal of infectious
diseases that was published in november
i believe where the top line result
of all collaborat all studies that were
included in the systematic review
said less than 10 percent of cases were
transmitted outdoors it is that
meta-analysis
that combines science from all sorts of
um all different science from from many
different places i think over 19 studies
were included
the top line result was less than 10
published in the journal of infectious
diseases one of our top infectious
disease journals
that is where that came from it was a
published study that synthesized study
for many places
with regard to camp i have a 16 year old
every day every year he comes home from
camp and he writes the number of days
until he returns to camp the next year
this year it got to zero and i told him
he wasn't going
i want our kids back in camp
we now have 38 000 new infections on
average
per day last may 11th it was 24
000 and we sent a lot of kids home and
camps were closed
the camp guidance is intended to get our
kids to camp
and allow them to stay there thank you
madam chair i would just ask unanimous
consent
that the full new york times story
uh dated today be placed in the record
because it answers i realize i'm out of
time
it answers dr wilensky's response
so ordered senator kane
thank you madam chair and thank you to
the witnesses for your
important testimony um
some of you have been before this
committee so often i can remember the
first time you were before us on january
24
2020 and so much has happened since then
and there's so much to talk about but my
colleagues have done a good job already
in addressing
many of my interests um at the last
hearing that we had together which i
believe was in march
dr fauci i talked to you a little bit
about long coven um
when the day comes where the president
declares that the national emergency is
over
there's still going to be at least two
challenges
long covered and then the mental health
challenges that
uh have resulted from a year of such
loss
um i want to ask dr fauci and dr
wolinski
to dig into a little bit how you are
using the funds that have been
provided to deal with the long covet
issue for folks who are suffering
symptoms
after they've recovered from coven
thank you very much for that question
senator this is really an important
problem
uh the nih has been given 1.15 billion
dollars
to study this and we're doing this in
collaboration with cdc and other
organizations
long cobit is a real issue anywhere from
10 to in one study as high as 30 percent
of individuals who recover from the
acute
manifestations of covid 19
who have virologically no virus in them
at all and they should be on the road
to an uneventful recovery but
unfortunately
what we've been able to find out now and
we're going to be putting together
a number of cohort studies to determine
the extent
the duration any possible underlying
pathogenesis
and any intervention but the symptoms
are somewhat common there's a
commonality among them
it's extreme sometimes debilitating
fatigue
muscle aches temperature dysregulation
you feel hot or cold
dysautonomia which is related to that
unexplained rapid heartbeat or
tachycardia
neurological symptoms and what people
refer to as
brain fog or the inability to focus or
concentrate
over an extended period of time these
are real symptoms and they can last for
a long time we have people that we
follow now
up to nine months or longer where this
occurs
it's a very important problem we take it
very seriously
we have a task force at the nih multiple
nih institutes not only my own heart
lung and blood and neurology and mental
health
all of which are going to be looking at
this over the next year or so
because it is something that we really
do feel we need to find out
what's the underlying cause and what we
can do about it
thank you for that dr fatchi that's
going to provide a lot of comfort to
people who are grappling with these
symptoms dr wolinski i want to
shift to the second concern that i have
again
we're not at a point yet where the
emergency is over and yet even when we
are at that point
the mental health impact of this very
very challenging time
on the american public and people all
around the world is very significant i
have worked closely with
colleagues including senator cassidy
really to pinpoint mental health impact
on
frontline healthcare workers who whose
experience of dealing with death and
illness at such a
massive scale having to manage end of
life conversations with people
who would normally be having those
conversations with their own family
members
this is a real significant concern my
colleagues supported
inclusion of provisions of the dr lorna
breen act and
the recent work that we've done and i
understand that cdc and niosh
are starting to focus on
the public information campaign to
frontline healthcare providers to reduce
stigma to seeking mental health
assistance should they need it
could you talk a little bit about those
efforts and more broadly the question of
the
keeping our healers healthy thank you
very much thank you very much for that
question senator and for the resources i
think it would be hard to
overestimate the the trauma that our
health care providers
our frontline workers have seen over
this last year
um having been there before i was here i
can tell you i'm pulling up to driveways
in your hospital that have morgues in
the parking lot is really
a striking thing to find i am grateful
for the resources we are collaborating
niosh
is collaborating with our injury
prevention center within the cdc
to create mechanisms and support tools
to uh do outreach for our our health
care workers and
uh and and i would also mention that you
know
we saw mental health challenges ahead of
covet 19. so these are not just
mental health challenges because of
covet 19 even among our youth between
2009 and 2019 before covet ever started
we saw 40 increase in mental health
challenges so we need this not just for
our health care workers
but through for the society at large
thank you very much thanks to marie
thank you senator cassidy
doctors thank you all for being here i
approach you now kind of as a physician
who's done research and vaccines
as much as a more so than i'm
approaching as a senator i was struck
and
by the way i'm incredibly frustrated and
the american people are frustrated
because they hear you're following
science but then they just have a sense
that the lag time between the
implementation of that and
recommendations
is far too long it's not just the
american people i'll put it this way not
just the people in my state
here's a stat article cdc slow cautious
messaging seems out of step with the
moment
want to go back to the office don't wait
on the cdc that's from wall street
journal and the liberals who can't quit
lockdown from the atlantic
um so first i was struck
when senator burr suggested that
previous immunization
actually confers immunity do any of you
agree with that
how much about you does previous
immunization confirm
does this previous infection confer
immunity it does we don't know what the
durability of it is but it certainly
does confer now so but we still
recommend that they be
vaccinated yeah we don't seems out of
step
no actually actually uh senator
a study has shown very clearly that if
you vaccinate someone who has
uh previously gotten infected and
recovered
the level of neutralizing antibodies and
t cells are extraordinarily high
not only against the wild type but also
against the barrier of that research
i've pulled some of that research
that refers to that right my concern is
that that would happen if you had
another infection all the inf all the
immunization does is mimic
a pre-existing infection that is very
well established with
other viruses no one has not established
it for this virus
and indeed some of this research shows
that within four days which is the
window period if you will
for an infection to become an illness
those antibodies
rise quite precipitously but we still
recommend that they get two doses
even though the same literature shows
that there is an increase
in side effects when someone gets a
second dose
and they've been previously immunized so
now not life-threatening but nonetheless
an increase in side effects
but nowhere do i see a recommendation
that well don't get the second dose
because the literature shows that after
one dose you've topped out your
immunologic response and you're at an
increased risk with the second dose
would anybody like to speak to that
so so there are studies ongoing to look
at uh the
first versus second dose i agree with
you it is a very reasonable
proposition for study but the purpose of
immunizing somebody who's been infected
previously
is to develop higher antibody titers
those high antibody titers are what is
so critical
in preventing if i may again the studies
and
other viruses show hopefully we have
research showing here but it appears to
that a second that a reimmunization
merely mimics
what would happen if somebody were
exposed to the virus
all it does is kind of mimic that which
would occur senator this is a different
virus
each violence is a different virus
doctor marches their research going to
explore that which i'm
referring to because the research so far
shows that within four days you get a
significant increase in anybody tighter
there there's research that's been done
to show that after vaccination
the nature of the immune response gives
sufficiently high
tighter antibodies that the all right
immune response that's with every virus
that is not unique to this
it's likely superior to natural
infection in this case in preventing
against some of these variants and i
think that's what dr fauci was getting
to
and i'll also point out that the
vaccines themselves and presumably the
previous infection
is also effective against the variants
um
by the way can people go back to work if
they've been vaccinated and not wear a
mask
assuming they're not immunocompromised
we have about a third of people in this
country who are vaccinated
we have about a third of counties in
this country that still have over a
hundred thousand a hundred cases per 100
000
we are working to to review our guidance
and to update our guidance we have put
out three
different guides sorry let me just ask
you again if i'm vaccinated and i have
antibody and i'm exposed to somebody
else
what is my risk of coming down with
symptomatic infection
um five percent five percent if i'm no
that's overall
not if i've been vaccinated and if i
have antibody that's if i'm vaccinated
overall
correct we don't have i don't think we
have data in what you're
looking at we did not check antibodies
on everybody who was vaccinated
but we could we we absolutely could but
to date we only have
and we do know that if we're in a if if
we know the critical mass or
our if we know that um herd immunity
is somewhere north of 60 or 70 percent
if we go into a workplace where within
that workplace
there is a hundred percent immunization
such as here
um we've achieved herd immunity
yeah there's somebody in here that may
not be responding to the vaccine but
because
everybody else has they're protected
that's nowhere reflected
and right now we have federal agencies
which we've had employees not working
for a year
because the union says that they have to
have special work pay workplace
precautions for them to return to work
there is consequence to this kind of
delayed as the stat article
shows of of the kind of updating of
these recommendations
the american people are incredibly
frustrated and as senator collins says
they're beginning to disregard what you
say that's true
because what you say so much of what you
say is patently not true
i have to wear a mask when i when i'm
outside and the wind's blowing at 20
miles an hour
that's been changed but it was only
changed recently they seek not to
believe those things
which are true you gotta realize
you gotta be more real time let me
finish with this
i think i don't know it was a stat
article the new york times appointed on
the hiv epidemic
the recommendations were much more kind
of calibrated to real life
listen we know people are going to do
this if you're going to do it
please accept this recommendation
this is a blanket walk outside and wear
a mask
you're vaccinated and everybody else is
in the room is vaccinated but you're
wearing a mask
the american people have just lost just
lost patience with us
but you guys i just asked you just kind
of be aware of their frustration
and get a little real time into updating
these things
i'm sorry to be so frustrated i respect
you all and thank you for your service
i yield back senator baldwin
thank you madam chair um dr wolinski as
you know
i led the effort to ensure that the
american rescue plan
included funding for cdc's work to
address variants of the coronavirus
specifically through
genomic sequencing i am really
encouraged
to hear from your testimony that we are
now sequencing 10
of our nation's weekly cases and this is
up from about
well less than half of one percent in
february when i introduced my tracking
covet 19
variants act a couple questions about
what we're finding
last month the white house announced
that it would
provide initial funding to jurisdictions
so that health departments could
conduct expand and improve activities to
sequence genomes and identify mutations
of the coronavirus
i'd like to have you describe how health
departments are making use of this
funding
and how this investment will improve our
response to future
public health threats but also uh any uh
new new variants that we should know
about that
particularly anything uh troubling
from the perspective of eluding the
therapeutics and vaccinations that we
have
uh uh produced thank you so much senator
i am
we are so grateful for those resources
in our ability to
scale up as you know we are now
sequencing about
uh 35 000 uh virus samples per week
that is a broad collaboration with
commercial labs
with public health labs with academic
partners and then with public health
labs sending
samples to cdc so we can address them
more completely in terms of moving
forward i'm looking forward to
bolstering the
infrastructure to be able to do these
sequences at the local level
to producing the infrastructure within
cdc to be able to follow these in a
pandemic related way
not just for this pandemic but for
future public health threats
and then further to expand our ability
in our workforce
in genomic sequencing in analytics in
bioinformatics
to be able to not just address covet 19
but these are long-standing things that
we are going to need
to address antimicrobial resistance and
other infectious threats
thank you thank you last week the
administration announced support for the
waiver of intellectual property
protections on covet 19 vaccines
to help end the pandemic i believe that
this news is the beginning of our work
to restore
america's public health leadership on
the world stage
but there's more to be done when it
comes to addressing covet 19
worldwide dr fauci can you explain how
increases in new cases of covet 19
worldwide
threaten the progress that we've made
here in the united states
and how can we avoid repeating history
when it comes to combating infectious
diseases worldwide
thank you for that question senator yes
indeed uh as we've said so often and it
is true
that a global pandemic requires a global
response and even if we successfully
vaccinate our population and get the
level of infection down
to a very low level as long as there's a
dynamic
of infection spread throughout
the world in any place in the world
there always is the danger that variance
will be generated and ultimately will
come
to the united states because of the
travel that we know
makes no place in the world separate
completely from any other place
in the world so that's something we
really need to pay attention to and it's
for that reason that i keep saying and
many of my colleagues keep saying
we really do have a responsibility to
the united states first
we do for sure but we also need to take
part in an effort
whatever effort and it's going to be
multifaceted effort to make sure that
the rest of the world contains
the outbreak and that could be from some
of the things we're doing right now with
india by giving them
immediate help with oxygen and drugs and
ppes
but also to provide for the availability
of doses of vaccine that we can make
available to them not alone not just the
united states
but the rest of the developed world
thank you
one quick last question to dr kessler
in its first few months the biden
administration has
surpassed every goal and expectation it
has set in terms of gang shots and arms
because of this effort we are moving
into the next phase of our vaccination
effort in which the focus is less on max
mass vaccination sites and more about
meeting folks where they are
to get shots to hesitant and
hard-to-reach
individuals as you know these vaccines
come with certain logistical challenges
and limitations including
cold storage and used by requirements
as well as specific numbers of doses in
each vial
as we shift to a more individualized
effort how will the administration work
to ensure that we are
using our existing vaccine supplies
effectively and maximizing the potential
and minimizing the potential for wasted
doses
senator uh a very very important
question
because as everyone on this committee
has recognized and has been part of this
heroic effort
you know initially certain decisions
were made
on how to maximize the number of
doses produced and the decision
in order to get the hundreds of millions
of doses
that we've already administered we've
had to
make certain trade-offs and that's why
you see the packaging
the way it is which is you know
in a considerable number of doses
and we have to reduce that uh packaging
but
every day senator i am in awe
of the contributions that many of our
local
community health professionals community
leaders
ordinary citizens are taking um
to be able uh to bridge the
the barriers that people are having
um so i would like to get this
eventually
down into very small individual doses
but that's going to take time
um and right now we're going to do
everything
possible to speed uh that up
thank you senator murkowski
thank you madam chairman thank you all
for being here
a lot of frustration this morning and i
think as senator cassidy mentioned it
kind of reflects the frustration that
americans have with where we are we're
all tired with
covid we're done with covid but as many
have said covet is not yet done with us
but
how how we're able to make sense of of
the guidance that comes out of cdc is is
critically
important um alaska was
very early on in making sure that the
vaccine was available
to uh to to all very quickly um
and as a consequence we were pretty
proud of the fact that that our numbers
of vaccination
were strong and we were number one in
the country but when you start out first
you also then are the forerunner
in demonstrating what it means to to to
really see this vaccine hesitancy and
we're seeing that play out in in
different
in different ways in different shapes um
so i appreciated
your comments dr wolinski to to senator
smith about the ways that we
can address the concerns that have been
raised whether it is where can i get the
vaccine
is it safe who do i look to for guidance
the state of alaska did a survey that
was released on thursday that indicated
that people are not looking to you all
for guidance they're not looking to to
our chief medical officer in the state
of alaska
they're looking to see what their
friends and their neighbors do they
don't care
what what their senator or the folks
from cdc do so we've got a lot more work
to be doing
with regards to that i want to speak to
my particular frustrations which you
have
had the benefit of multiple
conversations with me and that is
how we can get our our tourist
sector back to work for even a small
sliver
of this season uh 1.3 million tourists
come to the state of alaska on a cruise
ship
there were 48 tourists that came to
alaska on a cruise ship
last year and right now it doesn't look
much better we've been working back and
forth with cdc
trying to to deal with these uh this
conditional sale order
after many months of requests we finally
get to a place where we think
we've got some guidance out there i just
at 11
30 got new information
that the cdc's last transit guidance
still requires
additional guidance to be published and
i say
yes it's minor but the fact of the
matter is it is still yet
one more gate that has to be gone
through
and and our reality is if you can't get
ships
turned north now there is
no season whether it is for one week or
one month and so
i guess dr wilinski i'm going to ask you
one more time
can you give alaskans any guidance at
all
with regards to the ability to
to to finally get this guidance
fully resolved you've got cruise lines
that are saying
we're going to require everybody be
vaccinated all of our crews will be 100
vaccinated we will require that
those who want to sail on our ships this
summer be vaccinated
those in the communities who are welcome
welcoming them
are also equally committed to the
vaccine so
should i just tell folks back home
don't even bother ramping up your your
your seasonal
operations because it's just not coming
we can't get that guidance from the cdc
first of all senator let me congratulate
you and alaskans for getting vaccines
into arms because you have been a role
model and being able to do that with
regard to sale
um i was here in march we were waiting
on 2a guidance that 2a guidance of
working with ports has since
come um we have been now engaging as i
noted we do with schools with our
consumers with our
key stakeholders we have had twice
weekly calls now with the cruise ship
industry to understand
what how they are interpreting their
guidance and what they need in order to
be able to get
boats back in the water that is our goal
for this season mid-summer was our goal
2a has been released to be has been
released our
our guidance on how we get conditional
uh
how we get trial voyages into the water
as well as step three released how you
get conditional sales certificates
all three of those have been released
they have we have been in this dialogue
with the industry so that we can
understand what are the challenges in
the current guidance that are being
that are hard to be met and we are
actually having these conversations and
then going back
and addressing those challenges uh we
had a dear colleagues letter
that went out after 2a and we have
others that are in the works so
we are working with with those in the
industry to do our best to get
ships back in the water this season and
we have actually agreed to a five-day
turnaround when those proposals
come to us well it was it was news to me
to again just see that there is yet
another thing that has come up just this
morning so i'd ask you to talk
to take a look at that my time is
expired here but i must
raise this fishing mask mandate
um if you if you think about those
mandates that really
don't make sense the fact that the coast
guard
is requiring because they it's federal
law
out there that uh persons traveling on a
conveyance or at a transportation hub
wear a mask for the duration of their
travel
so i've got i've got fishermen
commercial fishermen
that are out there in the water i've got
crabbers and salmon fishermen
and cod fishermen that are trying to
deal with a mask because they're
concerned
about failure to comply
this is this is more of a safety hazard
than anything else you're out on a boat
the winds are howling your mask is soggy
wet
tell me tell me how anybody thinks that
this is a
sane and a sound policy to do
so i we've got a situation right now
where the fishermen
are more concerned about the liability
in failing to to have the mask on
rather than prudent marine safety
protocols this this is
is absolutely absolutely
a a a crazy policy i just don't
understand
i don't understand how we put
our coast guard men and women in a
situation where
they know that safety is at issue a
broader safety
issue than than the fear of transmission
when you are outdoor in the elements and
uh
and you are now being required to to
wear a mask so i would hope that the cdc
would reconsider
this quickly quickly quickly we're in
the process of finalizing
industry-specific guidance for exactly
this reason
thank you thank you thank you madam
chairman thank you um we will
turn to senators murphy marshall and
hassan a vote has been called i'm going
to go over to the floor and vote
senator uh we'll preside and i will be
back
as quickly as possible we'll go to
senator murphy uh thank you chairman
murray uh
thank you all for the fantastic work you
do to protect the country
just a quick word on this frustration
you're hearing regarding guidance from
the cdc
um i mean listen our witnesses today
could sit here
and claim that we have definitive
information on risks
or means of transmission or asymptomatic
transmission but they wouldn't be
telling the truth
and we suffered through four years with
a president who literally made things up
about this virus who simplified the
story over and over and over again
because he thought simplifying things
and being
definitive would make him look good
including giving
free medical advice to americans on what
therapies they should take
making claims that the virus would
disappear after a matter of weeks that
wasn't good for the country
it didn't help us fight this disease we
still have a lot to learn
and so i frankly appreciate the fact
that we have leaders
today who recognize that we still have
gaps in information who occasionally may
er on the side of caution in order to
save lives and i
share the frustration um
but the frustration is rooted in the
fact that we are
still less than a year and a half
into a virus that we're still beginning
to understand
um and so to that end
um dr wolenski
on this question of outdoor transmission
so senator connells was asking you about
a paper you put out suggesting that it
could be 10
of cases there's other folks that say it
could be
one percent of cases there are some
epidemiologists who say that it could be
0.1
of cases
that's a really important difference and
i
assume the difference between five
percent and point one percent would
likely
educate decisions you would make about
what recommendations you make to summer
camps
um how do we on this question
close the the gap in information that we
have given that there are
so many competing analyses out there of
outdoor transmission
what do we do to try to make sure
especially heading into this
summer that we have the best information
possible how do we solve for this
problem thank you senator for that
question i think it's important
for to realize that we at cdc are
responsible for putting out guidance for
individuals
as well as for populations for public
health we're responsible for putting out
guidance for counties that have
less than five cases per hundred
thousand and for counties that have
greater than a hundred cases per hundred
thousand
as well as for counties that have less
than ten percent of people vaccinated
and counties that have more than fifty
percent of people vaccinated our
guidance has to be science-based for all
of these situations
um in our last iteration of uh uh what
uh vaccinated people can do safely do we
did
update our guidance not only for not
wearing masks outdoors
but also for not wearing masks outdoors
in certain settings for people who are
unvaccinated
in those situations we also said you
know if people are gathered with other
unvaccinated people
dining with their masks off and close by
there may be a risk to that if they're
dining close by
certainly this meta-analysis that was
put forward um that demonstrated the
top-line result of
less than 10 transmission occurring
outdoors
was helpful scientific evidence and we
are following the science as it
continues to emerge
i think it's also really important to
recognize that now with vaccination
of 12 to 15 year olds our summer camp
guidance is probably going to have to
change in those settings and we
plan to do so great um dr kessler
question for you on booster shots you've
got uh
you've included in your testimony um an
expectation that we
may be in the business of purchasing
or and distributing booster shots maybe
as soon as later this year
um i i asked a question the last hearing
about the transparency of contracts
uh with the companies that are supplying
vaccines i still think that we could do
better
in terms of letting the american public
know and policy makers know
about the financial terms of these
contracts but what do we
expect with when it comes to contracting
for
booster shots are we going to go back to
the same companies
that provided the vaccine are we going
to open that tender up to
a broader set of companies um
how do we expect the um the process
of procuring uh
booster shots to work and how do we make
sure that it adequately protects
taxpayer dollars
senator thanks for the question very
important we're in that process
now in order
um to plan because that's really what
we're doing if we want
a vaccine let's say uh
both the duration of immunity
you know increasing age so there's less
uh antibodies and the variance
we have to take all those things uh into
uh consideration
and if we want vaccine um
end of the year we have to do that now
and we are in fact
um uh in those uh negotiations
the the best science to date
i mean the data we have um
and i don't want to get too technical
but the question is are we dealing with
homologous boosts
or heterologous boosts basically are you
going to boost with the same
vaccine or are you going to can you
switch that out and do mix and match
and that requires data we're collecting
that data and it's going to be the data
that
um drives what we boost
with um but for planning purposes
i think the the simplest and safest
assumption and i underline the word
assumption is
that it may be for the at least the
short term that homologous boosts
with the same type of vaccine makes the
most
scientific sense but i need a couple of
more
months in order to give you a definitive
answer but i have to plan now
so specifically to answer your question
uh we're dealing with the same companies
because we want to
continue uh with the safety and efficacy
that we've seen in those vaccines down
the road
that may change as we get other for
example protein-based vaccines
available senator i'll just say this i
hope that this committee
is is actively involved with the
administration on
um the construction of those contracts
um
to make sure that we're adequately
protecting
uh our taxpayers investment thank you mr
chair uh senator brown
thank you sandra burr dr wolinski um
i think from the get-go there's been
that uncertainty of when we arrive at
the moment when uh many of us feel that
this is truly in the rear view mirror
and
from the early conversations i've had
being on this committee
it's always been interesting to
understand
i think if and when that comes with
clarity
that's the only way i think we get true
comfort back into the country
uh senator murphy others have mentioned
how things have changed
goal posts have moved i think that's
inherently confusing to people
especially ones that might have other
reasons for not
getting vaccinated and i think that is
so important that we get there
everyone vaccinated um
my question is i think on the education
side of it more
emphasis and resources need to be put
into rural america i think along with
the logistics that have uh been some
effort made there to improve it i think
it's inherently more difficult
to get vaccines in the arms when it's
spread out
in areas like that um but i'd like you
to
zero in on it was three feet or six feet
and then three feet
uh indoors and outdoors so many things
have evolved and i think
with something as uncertain as this it's
uh
natural to have that dynamic where
in time and does natural infection
go along with vaccination to have
some weight in that point in time where
cases really start to fall off the chart
thank you so much for that those
questions senator maybe i'll start
uh briefly with the rural and say um you
know
in our efforts over this last several
weeks um resources have gone
broadly to rural communities we are now
funding uh federally qualified
healthcare centers getting vaccines into
areas
um in those centers over 5 million
vaccine doses have been given through
federally fqhc so we're we're we know we
need to do that outreach and that as
part of this next chapter in terms of
the six versus three feet i think
from the school guidance i know from the
school guides the first iteration that
was put out in february the biggest
challenge to getting children back to
school
was the six foot guidance what happened
soon thereafter is science emerged
and because sex six feet proved to be
such a
challenge within a month we had three
studies that demonstrated that um
three feet and six feet were equivalent
for younger children and so it was based
on those science
i would really like to say that we're in
a static situation here and that the
science isn't changing but we are
changing our guidance with as the
science evolves and as the science
emerges
and we have to remain humbled to that
science
with regard to your question um
regarding natural immunity we we have
several challenges there the cdc on its
website has a map
of presumed of um seroprevalence by
state
um as to how much there are how much how
many people out there have antibodies
and of course
we don't know all of the infection that
has happened right because much of this
infection has been asymptomatic
as dr fauci has said that that
prior infection likely confers some
immunity it might confer
full immunity for some period of time
but i will say that we're still
learning and and being humble here this
past week our genomic surveillance
data demonstrated that 72 percent of our
sequences are now the b117 variant
what do we know about how long prior
infection
will last with regard to new infection
and a b117 variant if you're not
vaccinated we don't have all of those
data yet we're doing studies we're
evaluating it
but i do think that um we should
continue to encourage vaccination of
people
who have had disease before
thank you dr falchi j
j vaccine which i think for many people
was a
preference in terms of just being one
shot had a high efficacy
rate to boot do you think it was a
mistake
in that we hold it when statistically
the rate of an incident was so so low
lower than i think on many other drugs
out there that seemingly have
much higher side effect consequences was
that a setback
that put us in a place that
has really hurt us or have we recovered
from it
i don't believe it was a setback senator
and i think if it was we certainly have
recovered from it because we now
know when you ask people there's a lot
of people who really want to get a
one-dose
vaccine who waiting for the availability
of this what i do think it did that you
don't fully appreciate
is that it really underscored how
seriously
we take safety because to call a pause
on a adverse event that as you mentioned
correctly
is really quite rare because at the time
there were six uh cases
in about uh seven million
people which is less than one per
million which is
really a very very low around the fda
and the cdc looked at the data
they wanted to find that if they're any
more they wanted to alert
the physicians who might be out there
seeing patients
about what the proper way to treat them
because there's one general way to treat
that people might use that would
actually be contraindicated namely with
heparin
so in the long run in the big picture
when all is said and done
i do not believe it was a setback i
think it really underscored
how how seriously we all take safety
how many vaccinations do we need to get
fully in the arms to be at
what the theoretical hurt immunity would
be in cases crash
anybody yeah i think that's going to be
a difficult number to give because
hurt immunity as a concept means you get
enough people vaccinated
enough people infected so that you have
a core of
protected people that's a blanket of
protection over even the vulnerables who
cannot
the threshold of herd immunity
is a number we don't know yet for this
particular virus
we know it for measles but we don't know
yet what that is we can
guess it's somewhere between seven that
uncertainty is probably the thing that
is going to be the hardest
thing to grapple with to get this fully
in the rearview mirror so
thank you lebron senator hassan well
thank you
ranking member burn thank the chair for
holding this hearing and
really thank you to all of our witnesses
today for not only being here but for
your service
uh before i get to a question uh dr
wolinski i just want to
second what senator murkowski said about
getting the guidance to the fishing
industry out as quickly as you can
i just met with my fisherman at the
yankee fisherman's co-op in new
hampshire this week
and we've got boats of fishermen who are
fully vaccinated who see the coast guard
coming telling them they have to keep
their masks on
not only is a wet mask dangerous out on
the open water
but because of the noise both the wind
and the equipment
these guys are used to relying on kind
of sign language on the boat
and with a mask on they really can't and
it's a real safety issue so i
i hope you will uh take this under
advisement and get the guidance out um
as quickly as you can uh dr fauci i
wanted to follow up a little bit we've
been talking about the very good news
um of the pfizer uh authorization for 12
to 15 year olds and
it looks like they may be seeking uh at
least emergency authorization
uh for two to eleven-year-olds in
september um and that's really welcome
news
but many families are still looking for
guidance about how to protect children
under the age of 12 from the virus
until a vaccine is authorized for them
especially as public health
restrictions are being lifted around the
country and i'm hearing some from
parents that
the schools are mostly reopened or
hybrid reopened but they're kind of
nervous about sending their children to
school so
what advice do you have for families
about what steps they can to
take to protect their children from the
virus while we await
fda authorization for use of the
vaccine for kids my recommendation
senator would be really to follow the
cdc guidelines i mean
but both when the children are in the
home with vaccinated individuals
the guidelines that clear what needs to
be done when they're outside
many things you can do without a mask
outside but if you're not vaccinated and
you're interacting
with people outside of the home from
different locations
you want to be careful and have the
children have mass so i think a good
following
of the cdc guidelines which as dr
wolenskiyer says
continue to evolve in real time as they
get more data
the guidelines get updated and upgraded
so that would be my recommendation
one other thing that i think is
important is that there's a lot of work
that we're doing now
in clinical trials to get vaccinations
for children younger than 12.
so a comp a bunch of companies several
of them are doing what's called
age de-escalation studies where we're
looking at children from twelve to nine
nine to six six to two and then six
months to two years we think
by the time we get to the end of this
year that we will have enough
information to vaccinate children of any
age
well that would be very welcome news to
a lot of parents so thank you
uh dr kessler i want to follow up on a
line of questioning that senator murphy
was
um following we've heard encouraging
news
certainly um that the protection from
the coven 19 vaccines remain strong for
at least six months and likely longer
but also that americans will need
booster shots as you all
may need booster shots as you all just
discussed um
it's going to be really critical that
these vaccines remain accessible and
that their price reflects the large
investments in american taxpayers
made in the research and development of
the technology so what steps should
congress take
to ensure that covet 19 vaccines
including booster shots if needed
remain available to americans even after
the end of the public health emergency
and how can we ensure that
pharmaceutical companies price these
vaccines in a way that account
for taxpayer investment
senator a key uh question
um let me assure you
um that because of what this committee
has done and your colleagues
on appropriations we do have the funds
uh to purchase the next round
again if if they
are necessary so we will be able to
purchase the next
round uh and to assure um
that if there are boosters they are free
just as the last round
i think um you raise a very uh good
question
beyond that uh beyond 2022
i mean i you know i look uh to your
guidance
and your colleagues uh on at what point
uh do you transition back
um to a commercial uh market but i think
for this coming round
uh we are going to proceed as we have
proceeded
and you've made those funds uh available
well i look forward to continuing the
discussion i see that i am almost
out of time here but i did want to just
ask dr wolinski
quickly can you speak to the importance
of continued access to covet 19
testing even as we work to distribute
the vaccine and
people are are getting we're building up
our community and herd immunity
yes thank you very much for that
question first of all um
we recognize that right now we we've
done an extraordinary job in getting
vaccine to a third of
uh americans and yet two-thirds of
americans don't yet have vaccine and in
fact our young
children will not have access to vaccine
for the rest of this year
we have put out 10 billion dollars
towards states to be able to
do testing programs within schools
some higher ed have been able to
successfully engage in this past
semester
through testing programs on their
college campuses we're going to need to
continue testing through our long-term
care facilities
as well as our correctional facilities
our dense
industries and so yes i think there
there has to be a huge
corner of what we are doing that is
related to testing
also surveillance water testing um
sewage testing to look for outbreaks so
we're doing a lot in the testing area
we're really grateful for the resources
to be able to do so
um once we have vaccine and the majority
of people
we are still going to have disease out
there and we're going to need to rapidly
be able to detect it
thank you thank you very much thank you
madam chair senator marshall
thank you madam chair dr falchi do you
think it's possible
that coven 19 arose from a lab accident
at a lab in wuhan
and should it be fully investigated that
possibility certainly exists
and i'm totally in favor of a full
investigation of whether that could have
happened
great is the possible coba 19 is not
naturally occurring again that is a
possibility
i don't know if we're ever going to be
able to approve that but you always need
to
open up and leave all possibilities
which is the reason
why i and so many of my colleagues are
very much in favor
of what the who said that they want to
go back again and take another look in
there
and see what was going on in that lab
and will you commit to get
this committee all the records anything
to do with any type of viral
experiment say from 2013 to the present
so we can review those
certainly i would comply with any
request of the committee
do you and others at nih have a conflict
of interest when determining if the labs
and lab work you helped fund
should be investigated and how it's
investigated
no i don't think it's a conflict of
interest we're very open and wanting to
make sure that
everything that has any question is
looked into at all
i have no problem with that okay
in 2013 president obama placed a
moratorium on viral gain of function
studies
with some loopholes which you uh were
able to
to to use at certain times i know we
disagree i know we disagree
we can discuss what's viral gain and
function and what isn't but in 2017 you
had a long process
and i assume it was you that decided to
lift this moratorium
and during this review my question is
this during the review did you
consider the risk of dual applications
by military terrorists or other foreign
actors
i'm not sure what you mean by that
senator did i consider
applications from dual actors i you know
we
say it again did you consider the risk
of dual application
that there might be other folks that
would use some of the the job function
discoveries that they might be used by a
military chair
or other foreign actors well in any
research that we do
we publish the research it's available
for anyone to use it in any manner
in which they can that's the that's the
you know modus operandi of the nih
we fund research the research is there a
national security
consideration though in in that type of
decision would they think in the viral
gain of function
this could be more powerful than the
nuclear weapons too
but to share that information with with
the with the government
right uh foreign actor maybe consider it
would have been like uh trying to do
uh the manhattan project in nuclear
energy nuclear weapons doing it with say
hitler or the soviet union
i'm not sure what you're getting at
senator but we don't fund research
we have committees that look at that to
make sure that research that is of any
potential danger
is not funded so i'm not exactly sure
what
what
your point is my point is is there
national security implications
with something as theoretically uh
lethal as viral gain or function
sure there is that's why we have
committees we have a p3co committee
which is the potential pathogen pandemic
pathogen
care and observation and oversight
excuse me
and that's a committee separate from the
nih that looks at
these types of grants to see if they
need to be funded so there is a
considerable
amount of oversight to make sure grants
that are doing research that would
obviously be of danger
is not so when you made the decision to
stop the moratorium
on gain of function was were their
national security advisors
in their in the room was their state
department was their defense department
who who were those people that might
have been part of that decision first of
all i did not make
the decision to stop the pause and gain
a function
if one looks at what actually happened
we put a pause on and i was the one that
was very much in favor of that pause
in 2013 in 2014
to 2017 the pause
was lifted because we established
a committee that looked at what we
called
p3co familiar with it right exactly
and when that committee then was able to
make decisions about granting
apart from the nih so that we would not
have any decision and it would be
i got one last question i want to sneak
in i still don't know that you answered
was there national security people in
the room when you
when that process that someone made the
decision i think you led that decision
but we'll come back to that
here's my last question if coven 19
is indeed a part product of lab
manipulation
can you sit here and unequivocally say
the viral studies that nih funded helped
fund
could not be indirectly or directly
related to this final coven 19 virus
yeah looking at this experiments that
were done that we funded there would not
be that possibility
unequivocally well you know they're
talking about
a uh a hybrid virus of a mouse
virus that was adapted to a mouse that
anyone that knows anything about
virology
would realize that that is not something
that would infect the human
much less be pathogenic and
transmissible
but we helped make the mouse that had
the hla receptor
that this copa 19 was specific for and
you were nih was involved
in the development of that humanized
mouse yeah yes
but as i mentioned in response
to senator paul the nih and niaid
did not fund gain of function research
to be conducted at the wuhan institute
of virology but that's not my question
you know the question is could some of
the
some of the funding you did you can call
it gain a function or not developing the
hla receptor at the mouse
i'm not sure if you're going to call
that gain a function or not probably not
but could could some of the funding
indirectly
ended up to the contribution of this of
coba 19.
i i i i'm not sure exactly where that
question is going i mean you could do
research on something as benign
as looking at something that has nothing
to do with it and it could
indirectly someday somehow be involved
so if you want to trap me into
saying yes or no i'm not going to play
that game but but we need to look at
that very
very deeply and consider exactly what
that's why you've committed earlier to
make sharing all the buyers
i'd be happy to share any information
you would like with the committee
thank you so much i yield back thank you
senator rosen
senator rosen i believe you're on mute
we're gonna hold one second for senator
rosen's
mute function to work
i believe they're trying to undo senator
rosen's
mute function from the studio um senator
rosen if you can just be patient
with us for a minute while we get that
fixed
um i'm going to go ahead and ask a
question and if senator rosen if you can
just hold for just a minute
i wanted to ask dr wilinski there are
various trades of cobit 19 that
threatened to disrupt progress made
towards ending the pandemic
and the cdc reports that the b117
variant is now the predominant strain in
the united states
we need to know which variants are out
there and how they're spreading
and why they and who they're spreading
to
which is why we approved 1.75 billion
dollars in the american rescue plan
to help cdc shore up its genomic
sequencing and surveillance activities
do you have enough data do you have the
right data and the right data systems to
be able to track these variants as they
spread
thank you senator um we are we have
scaled up our sequencing dramatically as
as i have noted um and uh every two
weeks or so we get an update in data and
we
look at the where these sequences are
just yesterday i believe
we the most recent update um that
demonstrated 72 percent of our
cases are now b117 six percent are now
p1
um and we're grateful for the resources
to be able to do so
uh generally our ballpark was to have um
10
of viral sequences able 10 of all
circulating virus to be able to be
sequenced
um and so with cases coming down and our
sequencing
rising up we've been able to reach about
that 10
mark right now um that has required
you know a lot of collaboration across
across uh government across
um commercial labs and whatnot um the
function
is a and and the impact of these whether
they are variants of concern variants
under investigation how we
how we um how we understand these
is related um to an interagency
collaboration with barda
nih and cdc in terms of seeing how
transmissible they are
as well as how well they function
against monoclonal antibodies in our
vaccines
thank you for that uh senator rosen do
we have you back
i i think we're back can you hear me now
yes oh very good
you know sometimes what zoom happens
there there you go well thank you chair
murray appreciate your patience
appreciate you calling this hearing it
uh
extremely important and so for you for
all the scientists the medical personnel
the frontline workers
i'm so grateful for what everyone's been
doing to be sure that
we can keep amer the american people
really people around the world safe
healthy and informed so
uh dr fauci when we last spoke in march
uh you shared that nih
had just launched a billion dollar
initiative to study the long-term
effects of coven 19
and identify potential of prevention and
treatment measures
for the long-haulers because copen 19 of
course is a novel virus there are so
many gaps
in our research and unknowns for the
people who've been affected and are
still suffering
and that's why i introduce bipartisan
legislation that will ensure that
nia nih will continue to be able to work
the cdc on comprehensive and
longitudinal studies of a diverse group
of coven 19 patients
i know some of the research has already
been done it's going to go forward
so you shared earlier some updates on
long covet could you speak to the
research gaps
that remain for learning more about the
long-term effects such as lung capacity
uh heart function some of the things
that people really seem to be
struggling with once they've recovered
from their initial symptoms
well thank you very much for that
question yes we have initiated
a series of studies first of all
building up
cohorts so that we can get enough
individuals
in the cohort to be able to do the kinds
of studies that you're going to do as i
mentioned
in response to a prior question it's a
multi-institute
endeavor involving multiple nih
institutes with differences
different interests and different organ
systems just
as you said the national institute of
heart lung and blood
is one that is looking at some of the
issues that you raised in your question
the national institute of neurological
diseases and stroke
the national institute of mental health
and my institute the national institute
of allergy and infectious diseases we've
also
just now started the request for
applications to be able to gather the
cohorts and do those types of studies
so there's a considerable amount of
interest in this and a major commitment
on the part of the nih to study this
thoroughly
to fill in some of the gaps that still
remain
as to what the pathogenesis of this
particular syndrome is
because it is a real syndrome that is
very troubling to a large number of
patients
thank you i'd like to move to the other
part of this equation which is the
therapeutic research and development
because even though people are getting
vaccinated
of course there's still people getting
sick and other people like we said still
suffering
a chronic uh chronic pain chronic
illness as a result of cloven 19.
and so we have to be sure that we have
those tools to continue to
to treat any cases that come forward so
could you
give us any updates about what
therapeutics might be in the pipeline
and do you think is there potential for
any of these treatments to help some of
the long haulers
um you know maybe it can treat acute and
chronic illness as a result of
the function of covalent senate
it's an excellent question but it's
almost impossible
to talk about treatment when you don't
know what the underlying pathogenesis is
so that's the reason why the studies are
starting off
by gathering the cohorts and trying to
find out if there is a mechanism
for some of the symptomatology the
profound fatigue
the muscle aches the temperature
dysregulation
the sleep disorder the brain fog as they
call it
so we don't know exactly what the
mechanism
of this symptomatology is and for that
reason it becomes very difficult
to do anything other than symptomatic
treatment for these individuals
that's why it's so important to do the
studies
that we're planning to do so that
hopefully when we understand the
mechanisms
we'll be able to have some therapeutic
intervention
well thank you i appreciate that because
uh um
it's really going to be important moving
forward it's going to be important to
our health care workers
to our surging of hospital capacities
and actually
globally around the world so i just
thank you for that i look forward to
reconnecting with you as we begin to see
more results of this
uh really important longitudinal
research and
the progress that it's making thank you
madam chair yield back
thank you very much um i want to ask the
the pandemic's
deadly impact on communities of color
shows we have a long way to go to
address
systemic racism and health inequities in
this country
black and latino people are receiving
vaccinations at disproportionately low
rates
and some of the systems that are
designed to make vaccinations
easier like online registration for
appointments have actually
made it harder for some like our native
hawaiian and pacific islander
elders additionally aapi communities
have experienced higher rates of
discrimination and violence as we know
since the start of this pandemic
so dr kessler i wanted to ask you how is
the federal government working to
decrease
coven 19 related health inequities
uh senator uh thank you for the question
uh enormously important um
there's some at least initial uh
good news uh you know we've seen the
deaths are
down dramatically since january um
and we all know that they're down 80
percent among seniors
but they also include that drop includes
a drop amount
among hispanics of 80 percent and among
african americans of about 70 percent
and in the past two weeks 55 percent
of the people vaccinated were white but
45
were non-white that compares uh to the
general population
that's about 60 percent white and 40
percent non-white
we have much more uh to do um
especially in the area of
confidence we do see that people's
confidence in the vaccine is increasing
black americans confidence increased by
24
points since january and latino
americans
confidence increased by 22 points since
january but outreach access
um is absolutely uh
critical these vaccines are free every
uh adult in america is eligible
uh in about 80 000 locations but we have
a lot more work to do
and we are keeping equity at the center
of the response
and we will not leave anyone behind
okay thank you so much for that effort
and and i appreciate it
uh senator bernie have any closing
questions or comments
madam chairman thank you yes i do um
i've got a little bit of cleanup if i
can
what i've been able to piece together
since we started
um and this is uh to you dr marks and
maybe dr
kessler oh bart assigned the contract
for 1.2 billion dollars for 300 million
doses of astrazeneca vaccine
that's currently authorized in 70
countries around the world its
manufacturing capacity in 15 countries
and 25 sites in addition to
the baltimore emergent facility two
sites in the u.s manufacturing
in ohio and new mexico of astrazeneca
vaccine
so here's my question of the stock that
we
currently have on hand which i estimate
to be about 60 million doses
is all of that being held because
it came from emergent or in that 60
million
inventory that we have today is some of
that either
foreign manufactured and or ohio or new
mexico
and would not have to be held up because
of the
current inspection concerns that
baltimore
senator i have been talking to
astrazeneca um
even last night i've been talking to
them regularly over the last
uh several uh weeks um
i to answer your your question very
specifically
the 60 million um that
you referenced all that drug substance
was made at emergent
there is uh another facility
um at catalan that manufactures drug
uh uh substance but we are not we've not
contracted and we are not
involved and that's for uh global
there are two other facilities one in
westchester
that you uh referenced that is for drug
product but everything that we have
uh involvement is in
that 60 that has been uh produced
uh for that first initial 100
um and they stopped at 60 when
uh because of the the problems uh at
emergent
were are all being are all being
reviewed by our colleagues at
fda because of issues that emerge
follow-up question of the
over two million that doses that went to
mexico million and half doses who went
to canada
have there been any indications from
those vaccines if they have
one i assume they have been used is
there any reason to believe that they
are reporting any
adverse effects
senator no and and those those came from
a time when that facility was not being
used
for more than one vaccine
to produce more than one vaccine sir
so the fact that they produce not only
a z but j and j
now makes them susceptible
um i it's it's a matter of public record
that the problem that occurred at the
facility
involved a contamination event between
uh
two vaccines okay um and that was uh
the issue that we are dealing with
but i just should add that you have our
commitment
that we are going to work as quickly as
we possibly can
to get both clearance of the
doses that are currently being held
because we don't
have clearance of the safety of those
doses yet
and also to get that plant back up and
running
in a manner that's fully consistent with
what americans
expect from their uh pharmaceutical
products
okay this this question uh i'm gonna go
to dr fauci dr marks and dr
lewinsky what percentage of the
employees
in your institute your center or your
agency
of your employees has been vaccinated
you know i'm not 100 sure senator but i
think it's probably
a little bit more than half probably
around 60 percent dr marks
i i can't tell you the exact number but
it's probably in the same range some
people vaccinated at our facility
and others at outside of the facility dr
winsky
we're encouraging our employees to get
vaccinated we've been doing town halls
and education seminars
we have our staff have the option to
report their vaccination status but as
you
understand the federal government is not
requiring it so we do not know
okay and listen
you're the face of why people should get
vaccinated
and knowing and promoting
and confidently given numbers
percentages i think is really really
important as we go into this last part
now if you tell me that
um there's some statute that says you
can't
require somebody to tell you imagine
being the parent
of a school-age kid who for generations
has been required to have their kids
vaccinated before they could start
school
and the fact that even within our health
organizations
we can't require that of people we're
going to have tough decisions to make
employers are going to make those
decisions
there have been decisions already made
by colleges around the country that said
if you're on faculty or your student
you're not coming next year if you're
not vaccinated
now they have the ability to do that
these are tough questions with even
tougher
answers but if we're going to get that
last
mile coverage we're going to have to
start portraying that we're willing
to do to ourselves what we're asking the
american people to do
dr wilinski i think it's safe to say
that the 21st century
is something that cdc has not totally
entered
but i'm confident that you're going to
take them there
and especially as it relates to science
and technology my question
is simple do you believe the cdc
director
should meet with private industry and
innovators who have new technologies
that can help modernize the cdc
um thank you i i think i have an
extraordinary opportunity as being
director of the cdc during this period
of time
um i think that much of what we're going
to need to do in public health is going
to take
collaboration with academia with
government
with private sector with nonprofits and
i am looking forward to engaging in
those in a transparent
open way so that we can have that
dialogue and create those collaborations
so let me go back and ask you one more
time do you believe that the cdc
director should meet with private
industry and innovators that have new
technologies
i i believe that we should in court i
should be encouraging all of those
collaborations and i am
relying on my senior leadership team my
subject matter experts to gain
engage in many of those conversations
but not you
if it's a subject matter where i'm an
expert i'd be happy to absolutely
um i think in a question to your staff
they suggested that
you couldn't um but
i'll revisit that through my staff to
yours
so i've got to say that i'm a little bit
confused
on the issue of cdc guidance after
hearing my colleagues
senator collins and senator cassidy
about it exactly who's involved in
content and language
so i sent to cdc
an oversight letter and uh
i got your response to it on 22 april
and i'll just highlight a few things um
cdc uses this emergency response
clearance protocol to clear items during
emergency responses
this emergency response clearance is
applicable to all cdc authored
cdc branded information products with
content related to
an active or ongoing response such as
covet 19 response the clearance process
consists of a series of formal
reviews approvals by relevant cdc
subject matter experts
smes and agency clearance officials
this typically consists of content
development and review by cdc's relevant
covet 19 response task force or smes
followed by additional review
coordinated by cdc's joint
information center at no
point given the opportunity did the
letter
mention anything about people outside of
government
could be parents it could be the
national education association
um it basically said this all happens
within government now
that's not what i heard my colleagues
say as it related to the guidance on
schools
that there was input provided by outside
entities
and as a matter of fact i went ahead and
pulled all the
email chains that i think was accessed
by the
the media outlets that made them write
this story
and i'll just say that
it's a little bit alarming because it's
all done on a timeline
and
it suggests
that aft leadership
not sure what the issue was they raised
but they certainly changed the language
of the guidance because there's actually
emails
that thank them for the language that
they provided and when you look at the
timeline between
that and white house announcement
one would have a hard time believing
that everything went through
a clearance process that was described
in the oversight response letter to me
so i i'd ask you to clear it up for me
if you would
thank you thank you for that question so
as i mentioned to
uh senator collins prior to
our putting our guidance through a
formal clearance process we do
an enormous amount of stakeholder
engagement to ensure that the guidance
can actually address the questions asked
in fact i can tell you
on the other side when i was a health
care provider at massachusetts general
hospital i would frequently call my
colleagues at the cdc and say we need
guidance on x it needs to address x y
and z
in the stakeholder engagement for the
schools we did outreach with
over 50 organizations we spoke to
teachers
we spoke to parents we spoke to
superintendents
we spoke to many different stakeholders
to understand what it is that they
needed from our guidance
as i mentioned previously in doing so
we recognized in meeting with the
teachers that we had actually failed to
comment
on what happened if teachers were
immunosuppressed
if teachers were undergoing chemotherapy
if they had a
family member with a transplant at home
how we were going to engage and provide
guidance to those
it was the cdc scientists that provided
the guidance
that provided the science around what we
should do it was the request
from teachers to say you didn't address
this issue and we hadn't
so the the first contact
by aft with your staff was on
february 1 monday february 1
and um
your staff person
uh wrote we were able to review a copy
of the draft
guidance dot or excuse me troutner with
the aft we were
able to review draft guidance documents
over the weekend were able to provide
some initial feedback to several staff
this morning
about possible ways to strengthen
documents that's on february 1 the
morning
on february 2
um
your staff emailed to you
that they had followed up with suggested
language on accommodations
per exchange uh
and on february 3
at a white house press conference you
say schools can open
reopen without teachers being vaccinated
would one reading this be concerned with
this timeline
and what the oversight letter told me
was the protocol that you went through
to have guidance signed off on
so um in the february third press first
of all i
in the february third press conference
that was before our guidance was
released
that was speaking to science and studies
that demonstrated that schools
had effectively reopened without without
teachers being vaccinated and keeping
students and children safe
february 3rd predated our guidance
release which i believe
was february 12th although i'd have to
confirm
you may recall at the time that in the
media i took quite a hit for um
commenting on that from teachers
themselves they were not happy with me
at the time
and with the success of
aft then nea engages you
and you actually committed to do an nea
town hall meeting is that right
we were engaging at the time with over
50 organizations um teachers
superintendents parents alike
at the time when our school guidance
came out as a matter of practice in an
unbiased fashion well i'm
madam chairman i'm going to ask that the
letter and
the um
the emails be part included as part of
the record
without objection i only make this
observation that
i hope you can understand why members
express
frustrations um on guidance that
there's a chain of information that
suggests
people had a preferred access to not
only
um advice but actual
language that went into the guidance um
i know what your answer to my last
question is going to be because of
i've stated it in one of the emails
should cdc guidance suggest that all
states should require teachers to be
vaccinated
i would encourage all teachers to be
vaccinated we spent the month of march
providing vaccines through our federal
pharmacy programs and we got over 80
of our teachers and educators vaccinated
as a as um
through that process so i am certainly
encouraging that all teachers be
vaccinated
i think that the the guidance with
regard to mandatory vaccination in
schools is going to be half to done at
the local level
would you provide guidance that
suggested to schools that they vaccinate
teachers we have been encouraging
vaccination of teachers all teachers
we have been encouraging vaccination of
all teachers of all educators of all
parents
is that in guidance um
i would have to confirm because i don't
know whether our most recent
updated guidance for schools actually
had widespread availability of vaccine
okay um the chairman's been awfully kind
to me and i'm not
trying to pick uh as i said when i
started
the next several months are going to be
extremely tough at getting people
vaccinated
i don't want any of us to lose focus on
what the mission is out there
and i know for all of you i'm
stating the obvious that we've got to
stay focused on vaccines
but
the confidence the american people have
in you
is a lot of what's going to make us
successful
um as dr fauci and i have talked
many times about thank god we had in
place in architecture that we perfected
over the last 20 years
that allowed things to happen
organically
like euas and this type of thing it
wasn't because we experienced anything
it's we we went through little red flags
h1n1
sars ebola where we looked at it and
said boy if this would have been the big
one
what would we have changed and
collectively we went through and changed
them
and we were much better prepared a year
ago architecturally
eighty percent of what we did was
following the statutes out
that's out there and the authorities
that were given to um
many of your institutes or agencies or
in dr mark's case
uh to the fda and i've got to tell you
that
i believe what the fda has accomplished
i never dreamed
they could do my goal now is to make
sure we don't roll back
because as we move into technology
platforms that's not something that is
easy to go back and do clinical trials
on again if you're just looking for a
new indication
but i've got to tell you that i believe
that
schools going back in person in the fall
is absolutely crucial to getting the
majority of the parents who have yet to
be vaccinated vaccinated
and um knowing that
at least by the end of this month if
we're not already there every
adult that wants to be vaccinated can be
vaccinated
uh it's time for us to start setting the
stage and paint the picture for what the
fall looks like
that people can go on vacation this year
and they can eat in a restaurant in the
outer banks of north carolina preferably
that they can plan their summer vacation
hopefully in a few more weeks or days
maybe they can go to camp
that in the fall we expect every school
to be in person
short of some drastic change in the in
the infection
uh glide path and next thanksgiving you
ought to plan to have thanksgiving with
your family
an extended family and christmas you
ought to be able to enjoy if we paint
that type of picture i believe david
we're going to get people vaccinated
but if we continue to fail at the trust
that they have in us making the calls
that are appropriate at the time feeling
like they're influenced in any way
feeling like we're not out there
where we need to be interpreting the
signs
we're going to fail and we're going to
fail for the american people but more
importantly we're going to fail
for the world because the world right
now is relying on
us getting to that number and us
providing the technology
and the manufacturing capacity for them
to be vaccinated
so we've got a big step ahead of us i'm
delighted that all four of you are here
today i thank you for the work that
you've done up to this point
and more importantly for the work you're
going to do in the future i thank the
chair
thank you uh that will end our hearing
today i want to thank all of our
colleagues
who are here i especially want to thank
all of our witnesses today thank you all
doctors
wolanski fauci marks and kessler for
joining us
to update on this fight against this
pandemic and to
tell you thank you to all of those who
work for you and have been diligent
in trying to make tough decisions in a
difficult time
to help protect all americans so thank
you very much to you and to all
the people that work with you for any
senators who wish to ask additional
questions questions for the record will
be due in 10 business days on tuesday
may 25th at 5 pm
hearing record will remain open until
then for members who wish to submit
additional
remarks and materials for the record the
committee will next meet tomorrow
wednesday may 12th to mark up the
nominations of justin samuels to be a
member of the equal employment
opportunity
commission jennifer abruzzo to service
general counsel
of the national labor relations board
and semananda to serve as solicitor for
the department of
labor without the committee stands
adjourned
okay
okay
amazing
good
okay
this
[Music]
so
um
um
there
is
i don't know sometimes they're so late
[Music]
great
so
[Music]
so